i think business is branded poorly
i think it's an art
i think it's as beautiful as a symphony
or a painting when done properly
and i think that for it to ever have
that space in society we must realize
how much these traits here
can be the catalyst of success
i'm going to redefine what an
entrepreneur and business person is
thought of
i think i can do it
honestly i genuinely believe my great
legacy may be that i made emotionally
intelligent soft skills alpha most alpha
males that are winning in business are
talking about very different things that
i'm talking about and i think it's an
important balance to the conversation
why can't you be kind why can't you be
empathetic you know i think a lot of
things that were taught around business
are the hard skills it's very important
but at the end of the day i really think
business is run by people with people
poor people and either i care more about
the money or i care more about a person
in the world running around saying who i
am as a man i choose the latter i don't
even understand what we're debating how
can you have an organization when the
asset is people where that is not the
thing we spend the most time now i can
be kind of like aggressive and
competitive but my absolute strength and
foundation to my success and often other
people's that i admire from afar are
predicated on their empathy and
perspective and gratitude and warmth and
i think the way i roll is going to be
the next era it's almost that i came
into the business world with the growth
of the emotional intelligence you know
and that it took me all these years to
realize that that was it
that's the book this was it this was
always it
i believe that
so much more
success happiness results are upon me
and hence why this book
is being written
now
[Music]
you